you guys are not gonna believe it team
avatar is back
hey everyone really awesome news about
the Avatar The Last Airbender Netflix
series with the new episodes that
they're producing so if you guys haven't
heard they're doing Avatar The Last
Airbender again on Netflix of course
I'll do videos for this series when it
actually drops so if you're brand new to
my channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the Avatar The Last Airbender videos
so they're basically doing a new version
of the original animated series which
right now is supposed to come out during
2020 so I don't know when the actual
premiere date is planned for but they
might push that a little bit just
depending on how production goes because
they just started casting it now so
we're probably gonna find out who's
gonna be playing these characters really
really soon
so yesterday Bryan Konietzko gave this
huge update on what's going on because
they had to move production offices just
because they're in a different phase of
the production now so we'll just read
his update here he posted it with this
picture of them walking around the
Paramount back lot I think this is the
Paramount backlog which actually isn't
too far away from where my old apartment
used to be but he says mike and brandon
walking between meetings form a short
while back I think Brandon is just one
of the other Nickelodeon production
executives the production studio on this
is Nickelodeon studios in Netflix
working together but obviously this is a
Netflix series we're moving into a new
office space transitioning into the next
phase of production our core team is
growing we're writing planning and
testing that means they're testing out
the look and the feel of everything like
bending obviously is the thing that
everyone thinks about first but
obviously that to start doing costume
test they just have to start getting the
look and feel of everything just right
before they actually start shooting
episodes they shot a whole bunch of
documentaries during the making of the
original avatar series if you're a big
fan you've probably seen some of them so
I'll play a couple clips from that just
so you can see what it looks like when
they're actually testing a lot of that
stuff out what differentiates the
essences of these different martial arts
forms firebending of course we use the
dynamic and artistic movements of the
northern Shaolin style
the powerful kicks the punches the low
stances the nearly acrobatic movements
it did cuts through the center of mass
of the opponent did slices right but his
message goes on to say though there's
plenty that's new for us in this
live-action process we've been on this
long roller coaster twice before because
he's talking about the original Avatar
The Last Airbender series and then
legend to Korra after that right now
everything seems slow and we're itching
to speed up before we know it everything
will be moving too fast and happening
all at once that's basically when
they're on set filming overseas I don't
know where exactly they're gonna be
filming a lot of this but I believe they
did some location scouting in China I
think they're trying to be as authentic
as possible to the setting for those of
you that are eager to see this new
series and are asking if we have a
trailer yet obviously everybody wants to
see a trailer thank you for your
enthusiasm sincerely but you wouldn't
want to see a version of this series
that was made within nine months the
nine months that he's talking about is
actually nine months from the date that
they announced it because the
announcement that they were actually
doing this series was last year Netflix
is like congratulations we're getting a
new Avatar The Last Airbender series
from the original creators M night
Shyamalan is nowhere to be found
they're gonna completely erase the
avatar live-action movie from your brain
Bryan just goes on to say too much
Hollywood fare is fast tracked in the
results speak for themselves
I think that's him throwing a little bit
of shade at the end night live-action
Avatar movie thankfully for us in this
series Netflix is committed to doing it
right meaning they're not locking them
down on an actual release date if they
need to take more time we're trying to
make something special that will stand
the test of time like the original
animated series one of the best animated
series of all time a live-action Avatar
series is a daunting incredibly complex
thing to pull off a fantasy travel show
with tons of VFX CG creatures martial
arts etc and to do it right takes a lot
of planning that's why right now they're
doing a lot of testing before they
actually cast the actors just because
they want to make sure that they can
pull off all the crazy bending moves and
they can make everything look the way
they want it to look on both the
original series in Korra when we were at
this stage in production the projects
hadn't even been announced yet the
difference with this Netflix series is
that all of you heard about it just a
little bit after we started so the thing
about this the timeline of the original
avatar series is that they
started development in 2001 but the
first trailer for it didn't drop till
2004 because it premiered the next year
in 2005 Mike was trying to pitch a show
around it's a different networks you
know he just kind of met with typical
frustrating response it's very you know
it's very hard pitching show you know
it's not easy to get momentum with the
studio and most of them were just like
oh we already have something like that
or we're not looking for something like
that at this time I remember Mike being
really frustrated and saying like that's
it I'm done I'm not pitching anymore I
was like forget that man we're gonna do
it together let's do it together I I
know we can do it as a team we talked to
Nickelodeon we asked him what they were
looking for and they were looking for
action-adventure legends at war we ended
up the first thing we ever pitched was
avatar and we came up with it and
pitched it to weeks later the reason why
the live-action series isn't taking them
quite as long from start to finish to
actually make is because they're not
starting from scratch but obviously
translating things to live-action takes
a little bit of time but the blueprint
is there they've already written a lot
of those stories so it's not like
they're making a new avatar the last
airbender series with new episodes doing
the same story completely rewriting
everything what they're doing is they're
expanding the original scripts because
it was a half-hour animated show and the
new show was probably going to be an
hour long per episode like 13 episodes
per season but each of them are an hour
instead of a half an hour so you have to
make the scripts twice as long but that
also allows them to do a lot more
character development for each of the
team avatar Korra characters which is I
think it'll be way way better at the end
of the day so right now if they're
planning for a 2020 release day maybe
we'll say late 2020 just to give them
the benefit of the doubt then we
probably wouldn't see the first trailer
till sometime early 2020 right now
they're casting the actors maybe they'll
start shooting by the end of the year
early next year that would allow them to
get it out late 2020 2021 meaning that
what they might do is just drop a
trailer at Comic Con next year not this
summer but the year after Bryan goes on
to say so it will seem like a longer
wait but we can assure you that everyone
is making good use of the time so we can
craft something beautiful emotionally
powerful and so we can make sure Appa is
cute we'll be starting the casting
process before too long so it
you're aspiring to be part of this thing
keep taking acting lessons and some
martial arts movement classes we'll
announce how when and where to audition
soonish
thanks love Brian there were a lot of
you that asked when I post my last
teaser video how can I actually star in
this if I'm an actor and I know martial
arts so he's basically saying that he'll
tell us in a little while so if you
really want to do that you might have a
chance the other big news that we've
gotten about this since I did my last
video is that Jeremy Zuckerman is coming
back to rearrange the music from the
original Avatar The Last Airbender
series for the new one once we knew we
were doing our chart we started amassing
random instruments this is a it's called
the Columbo and it's a African computer
this is a Chinese lute another extremely
old instrument I don't would even call
this I guess be drums it sounds like a
battle cry or something you got a
splinter for me this is a Dudek I mean
in wind instrument
[Music]
these are all over avataric sir no big
surprise there the music for the
original series was fantastic so you
don't really need to change it at all
you just need to re-record some of it so
if you really loved the original
soundtrack it just sounds like he's
gonna refresh it a little bit maybe make
it a little bit bigger because it sounds
like Netflix with their deep deep
pockets and unlimited money supply is
giving them all the money in the world
to make this look and sound amazing and
one of the drawbacks of the original
Avatar The Last Airbender animated
series at Nickelodeon is that the budget
for a lot of those animated shows avatar
included is pretty low even though the
original avatar series and then Korra
after it have beautiful beautiful
animation by the time they've gone to
Legend of Korra
several years later the animation became
a little more sophisticated I think they
were able to spend a little bit more
money on it because Nickelodeon loved
the original avatar series so much there
are similarities but then because we are
kind of evolving the whole animation
process things were but still one of the
benefits of going to Netflix is they're
known for overspending on content and
because Disney is pulling all of its
Marvel Star Wars Pixar stuff because the
Disney Plus streaming service Netflix is
desperately in need of amazing original
content so Avatar The Last Airbender is
one of their few things that Disney does
not have one of the best series of all
time seems like a really easy slam-dunk
as long as they take the time to get it
right which it sounds like they are I
know a lot of people are worried about
Netflix's take on animation done as
live-action like Full Metal Alchemist
became a live-action movie the
live-action attack on Titan movie wound
up being really terrible it's almost
nothing like the original animated
series I don't think that that's
something that you need to worry about
for the Avatar series because Mike and
Bryan are doing it and it seems like
they're being very authentic to their
original work it's not a situation like
the M night live-action Avatar movie
where you have somebody who's not
involved with the project at all coming
in to do their own spin on it and just
making up a whole bunch of stuff on the
fly this is a clip of them actually
testing out a lot of the bending styles
with Sifu ki soo so if you don't
remember this is from the Avatar spirits
documentary which I think they dropped
right around the last season of Korra
when that aired a couple years ago so
cool case you
I was the martial art consultant a huge
component of obviously making martial
arts epic is the martial arts and we
didn't want to just like copy stuff from
movies and new that would run dry pretty
quick we pitched in the concept and he
just lit up you know he got it right
away and he started talking about
tornado power he talked about airbending
in this little monk it just immediately
came to me ba gua which is this based on
the book of changed the H hing the
waterbending was something you know soft
that just fit tight she completely the
fire nation called for the you know
crisp long clean right now my early
guess is is that what they might do is
split this into five or six seasons
because I think Netflix wants as much of
it as they can get
so they expand all the half-hour
episodes to a full hour and they end the
first season with the winter solstice
part two with an getting the big message
about what he has to do next maybe they
do it just like a little bit more than
that so that season two winds up ending
with the siege of the north part two
where Aang learns to water Ben and
repels the Fire Nation that huge WTF
action scene here's my big question for
you guys though obviously if Avatar The
Last Airbender is a big success for
Netflix and for this live-action process
they're gonna want to do another sequel
or prequel series so I think it's pretty
good bet that after they would do in
Avatar The Last Airbender series they
would do the same treatment for Legend
of Korra and then after that would you
guys want them to do a prequel series
say do an avatar Wan series or would you
want them to do another avatar because I
think it's a pretty safe bet that Steven
Yeun would love to come back and cameo
in a live-action Avatar The Last
Airbender prequel series about avatar
Wan and if you didn't ever watch Legend
of Korra avatar Wan is the very first
avatar so it would be amazing if they
actually did a new version of that
series so we'll find out more about
what's going on with production later
this year but leave all your avatar the
last airbender video
request in the comments below if you
guys didn't see it a little while ago to
the really cool thing that Aaron Haas
who was one of the best writers on the
original avatar series did was talk
about the planned season four in the
Azula Redemption arc that he had planned
let me know if you want me to do that
avatar planned season four video because
it's actually pretty fascinating to hear
him talk about what their plans for the
Azula character work
she was already one of the central
characters of the show but they were
just gonna focus more on her during
their next season so what will happen is
is they actually just dropped a new
teaser for Rick and Morty's season 4 so
I'll do a video for that we also learned
about Rick and Morty season 5 that'll
post later today so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
all the videos when I post them no
worries wait wait for everything click
here for my Avengers end game deleted
scenes video with Iron Man and
spider-man that last big scene and click
here for my Game of Thrones Season 8
deleted scenes video thank you so much
for watching everybody to stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]